all right Nikki yeah Nikki where you
from originally where I grew up in
gardena a Compton area so you're the
only girl
yes captain girl la girl yeah tell me
about your family you grew up with both
your parents I know I grew up with
neither one of my parents even though I
grew up in a home with parents I'm a
foster child so sitting away from my mom
I wouldn't your zone yeah you know what
I was born in a t30 so she probably you
know crack my tea came into play cocaine
you know drug thing that's the the hike
your hike how was your you know what my
foster mom and foster father were a
little older I would say my upbringing
is it was actually pretty good though oh
it kind of instilled some good morals in
me you know so there's nothing nothing
crazy happened um there was a few
different things that happened while I
was there in a home but it you know
nothing that my foster mother or father
kind of knew about you know like
well I had foster sisters and they were
into you know I'm saying like the sexual
thing and introduced me to you know
whole thing of sex so when I was younger
every year um at a very young age not an
appropriate age to you know I'm saying
to open to open or introduce something
like that to a person so I'm
particularly you know that's one thing
that I did remember and didn't know at
the time that it was wrong okay you know
older I got I end up figuring out that
it was a little bit wrong but your
foster family your parents didn't know
about it no they knew nothing about that
at all
they did drugs in the picture at some
point um drugs didn't come in the
picture until I got a little bit older
and I wasn't really doing the drugs and
I want to say my first time around drugs
was when I first started smoking weed
weed is my first love weed is my first
day they worry about today are using
crack today today I'm
I'm indulging in crack cocaine I do
still smoke weed cigarettes cigarettes
on purpose I don't do any other drug
though so you know not saying that I
haven't actually you know sample data
tried it before I think I tried crystal
before I tried snorting coke I haven't
really did the hair line but I think I
think I mistakenly I think I mistakenly
had it it might have been mixed in with
some of the crimes or something or what
a work of some dope you know because it
was around and I smoked it all night
except by then you know it's kind of
weird it was kind of weird not realize
you know what I'm saying that that was
going on but but yeah I accidentally did
that but I smoked it
yeah and then which you'd see Lakshmi
the parents house at what age I was
taking with my mom and dad at one
couldn't afford home I was taken out of
my foster home because my foster mother
she died of cancer and my foster father
quote unquote my foster mom she had a
daughter of her own my foster father had
a daughter of his own home so how does
the foster assistant work so he'd be
here in a foster home and two people
come over a couple comes along to take
you yeah it could be a single person it
could be a single permanent can be just
a woman usually bring you home and
you're part of the family or they visit
you at the foster home no no no what my
real mom and dad know you're the foster
here no no the the foster parent you
live in the home we lift the parents oh
so you're not in their home yeah and
they're so you go home and so you're
either kid yeah basically Lane they take
care of you look that situation of
religion I love that I'm at ten we come
all together all together I left out of
the system and like seventy why did you
leave that a town huh why did you mom
because my foster my foster mother at
the time died of cancer and my foster
father is a daughter his actual birth
daughter blood on her own told them that
he couldn't take
me are my foster brothers and sisters
because that possible isn't sister's
name house attend you go back to the
foster one huh it's attend you went back
to the system I went back in wall
because you just go from one home to the
next so I went to another foster home
temporary and then there was one more
foster home temporary and then I went to
a placement placement it's kind of like
what they call a group home so there's a
lot of other girls there there's a lot
of other girls there there might be
houses that separate us girls maybe like
anywhere between six to eight girls in
each house you know like this one I was
in David and Margaret so you have about
three or four different houses in each
house there's about 10 to 15 girls it's
on the same same same you know plot land
or whatever it's just a big area so you
have an office being had the driveway
you have a lawn area and you have the
houses boom boom boom boom
you know but we're all still in the same
you know the same the same property and
we're all on the same property so each
house has a kitchen bedrooms own staff
member own staff member and own way of
running the you know own kind of program
for the day so they might separate the
houses from ages or they might separate
the houses from
appropriate appropriate um others that
surround you like they might have a
house that's for girls that are just you
know I'm saying that might be a little
bit more Vince Li disabled and need a
little bit more help maybe a little bit
more handicapped they might have a house
for handicapped girls and then this
might be for the older girls middle-aged
girls younger girls however they
separated so I went to placement down
after and then after that one I went to
another placement another another
placement group home that was far out
that's because I had I love this just up
and right you'd run away yeah oh yeah
I'm liking what I was saying I'm go do
you have any pleasant memories of your
childhood only when I was in the first
home you know what that's a lot I didn't
have this placement that I went to is
called Oak Grove and I had some good
memories there too we didn't stop there
was a lot a lot of us kids and stuff
there too you know saying I was
age 18 and under so uh reason when I
have like really good memories of that
there is because um they have daily
activities so I'm leaving I like field
trips to think you know man we went the
basketball games football games baseball
games we go out to the beach
we have all types of the sporting
sporting competitions there the
placement with each other between each
other your experience that you're
telling me about is so different from
some of the other foster system stories
you know what it just all depends on
what they would be member it's all
depend on what they remember because
there was a lot of us I was in there and
it all depends on what placement you go
to too
and at what time in your life so you
know at that time of my life
you know I had the ability I was still
mentally functioning I wasn't on any
medication I know I had like a little
bit of an anger problem and I know that
I was a very stubborn very stubborn so
at that time you know but I still was in
a place in time of my life where I was
able to you know participate in those
things that they had that they had
available for us you know
so too when you are on your own 18 you
said yeah nan 17 18 um I got emancipated
where'd you go though um basically the
streets streets I've been on the streets
- ever since I was supposed to be like
in placement I'm setting and then in a
transitional living but because of
because of you know my situation at the
time and me wanting to me saying oh my
god I'm emancipated out of here hey
I bumped out I was in the streets 24/7
you know how do you support yourself uh
you know let's support myself by
starting to do this tell jokes so drugs
I saw I saw Michael Kennedy for years
I'm so crack cocaine for years I would
I'm likely to call the dead girl any
idea you know black girl so that's all I
said
two years and that's how supporting us
yeah a lot of females I hear actually
are very successful in selling drugs
yeah yeah is that why is that you know
what because depending on what drug II
do the the main the main customers are
male you gotta think about it
the main customers are male so if a man
wants up don't wants to buy some dope
who do you think he's gonna go to the
girl or the guy and if the girl is
pretty who do you think it's gonna go to
first to get the dope you know I'm
saying
okay and he don't care if the girl gets
too small it's just because he you know
some have no fetishes but us girls we we
would tone like me I'll take my name is
dasha
- booty okay you don't saying on my
startup Aditi something like that
somehow fetishes they'd rather take the
goat then I'm gonna pull out my [__]
and buy just to think about it I'm about
to go down here and grab the bottom of
this you know I'm saying and actually
sell it wasn't done oh yeah yes so you
know a Jesus all depends on where you
guys minds right and then I come to find
out that downtown LA has the the highest
number of sex offenders oh yeah
there's so so so at the end I thought
about it too you know there's a lot of
sex offenders out here whether they're
staying in a tensor in the building's
well they're not allowed to be close to
schools they're not allowed to be close
to school there's no guarantee this is a
perfect area there's no schools in this
area there is a school in the area if
you go to 6th Street oh this right here
in the series there's a school in the
area but they're far enough away where
you live right here in this building if
you live right here in this building the
time if you look at the Megan's list
website there's thousands and thousands
of them right here and I strip down on
that but there's a lot of sex offenders
in the area you know and they all have
certain type of fetishes yeah
so that that you know I'm saying
they need a smoke crack and I know this
guy now because I'm so packed for so
long and I started indulging in it I
started using it on a regular on a
normal regular basis so by doing that I
end up opening myself up to the other
side of the dope game you know I'm
saying which is the using part the me
opening myself up to that and being the
user not the selarón I've noticed that
there's so much sexual activity you know
I'm saying involved and some sexual
activity going on to where it's like and
then and then what else what are you
doing for money now um you know what I'm
trying not to indulge or involve myself
you know I'm sitting in the regular and
the regular comings and goings of which
is like prostitution stuff like that
like I say don't get me wrong I've you
know what they call call quote time to
date you know I don't stand right on the
corner and say oh yeah I don't have a
beautiful being out with you gets
proposition they proposition you or your
attendance once a day you walk to the
store you're gonna get hit up at least
once a day
I've already gotten ADA I'm telling you
how are you gotten hit up once already
today so that's just open
and that's just the opening of so they
constantly do that they do that and then
I was just cuz I was just talking with
one of my homeboys and I was saying I
noticed that now since I'm on the other
side of the fence I know this you know
I'm saying that I get a lot of
propositions and sometimes I feel
offended sometimes I feel offended that
they get at me like that because when I
was out here selling but ever ever I
might get something I will try not let
me like that but I always tell them no
strictly business and next time please
don't do that
you know I'm saying otherwise I'm not
gonna [__] you come to buy your dope you
don't come to proposition you're not
coming to Houston I listen you come and
ask if I might up that's what you do and
what to do you have kids if your own
children yes I - I had I had those
children
right before the really comings and
goings like really getting in deep it
selling go okay I still so dope before I
got pregnant but once I had my son then
that's when I really got deep into it
but I was so I could basically say until
after I had both my two children and
when I really started selling drugs and
to support everything because it costs a
lot Mikey keep chopping you know and get
y'all you know I'm saying throughout so
eight thousands of dollars did you even
raise your kids huh did you raise your
kids um my daughter my daughter yeah
well I said Otis only to a certain age
my my daughter if she was really really
young I was really young when I had my
daughter I was barely 14 not my daughter
I turn 14 October I had my daughter
March really yeah 14 years old yeah
razor
no there I was putting a foster home
and um I made an agreement with my
foster parents that you know I'm saying
that they would kind of take over to
care to care for her I was you know I'm
thinking maybe a 14 I did I was a little
advanced for my age as far as mentally
is concerned but knowing my
responsibilities knowing what I was up
against not up against her you know I'm
saying what my what the expectations
wasn't being a parent um it was I wasn't
ready for that I wasn't that advanced
you know I wasn't that mature so I made
grieving with my foster parents if they
help me take take care of her and then
in turn I end up going to jail and then
and then that's more that was more time
away on more time that I was unable to
you know be around her and then it
seemed then once I got out placement
yeah that that was about it I think in
the job I did trying you don't send a
conductor you know try and get a
relationship you know I'm saying it back
with my child and going in there and
being there on a regular basis but it
was kind of hard because the first
parents that I had that I had asked to
take care of her for me
so they kind of restricted how and when
you know saying and how often
you want me to come in you know I'm sin
and then boom disappear you know for
days we decided to hunt that's hardly a
child suit especially when a child knows
the children love them so it would kind
of got me and said it has me upset at
that and still thinking that that was
unfair was that we them not actually
giving me a chance to you know like you
know I'm saying more of a chance or at
that time in my life where you know I'm
saying that they'd given me the chance
to be able to do that you feel me many
things would have turned out a little
bit more better where you know I'm
saying I would have a relationship with
her you know could you have a second
child as well I have to I have my son to
movie
so you never really have contacted
heater of your kids no not recently then
of the numbers that I have been calling
for some reason nobody's answering you
know so I've gotten to a point where I'm
at a point where I'm gonna start going
and knocking on some doors you know
because there's particular places people
that I can go and see you know I'm
saying and inquire but I only do that on
you know I'm saying her urgent basis or
if I just period can't contact them at
all so that's where it's gotten a point
to do I can't contact them at all so do
you do you envision one day getting
clean off a crack and he's getting all
quarters I mean I was kind of I was you
know I'm saying I was clean before in
it's not necessarily it's starting to be
an issue our problem but a lot of people
that died knew it before I started using
they really don't want me using this
[__] they won't be using it from
beginning
so with that being said you know they
they can't wait till I stops you know
they can't wait to have that movie you
know any plans any like you see happen
in your life I could be wrong but I
swear that I've turned indulging into a
business
I want to be able to
I'm gonna be able to if I continue to
constantly if I continue to keep
indulging you no other way that I've had
the ability to turn it into a business
damn I felt like that I'm I'm a smart
woman
even though it you know I'm saying using
the drug but I'm I swear I've been able
to turn it into a business anyway huh
what do you mean by okay so I have a
tweet that I like to do
do what ever to trying to do a knockdown
right I have to do my go meditation some
people like to a video recording
sometimes without me you know they're
able to take those recordings in music
record yourself
whatever people will go online to
actually view your video or see you live
doing it okay
if every minute comes six dollars and
you're on there for an hour and you have
ten ten people for six minutes and
you're on there for six hours
do you like a webcam girl for how much
money buddy think about it you do it
naked you might make tons of money
you could do a live you know how long I
think you know what they can see that
they can't see you you might enjoy a
shower you might be onto something there
unless it's the healthiest thing to do
gives you an audience for that my babies
hey you know the mystery of turns people
on like I say certain people have any
shoes all right where do you stay out um
you know I'm popping around and do this
work yeah I'm around in the area but
memorize her just and particular faces
you will catch me whole Crocker and any
point of time together yeah so and go
over there I feel a little bit safer
all right Kiki well thank you so much
for talking to me thank you good luck
with whatever you're doing okay
oh this was a little bit better theirs
was a little bit sober them so I can't
you know in the morning right yes I
can't buy I was like oh let me go over
there I'm sober yeah how many times have
you spoken by four four times you yeah
yeah this is the boys when we're talking
you